thank you
to come here
um
first of all let me just give an ad for
a position in the check Academy of
Sciences in Prague on uh on my grant to
work on proof complexity or bounded
arithmetic
so uh the deadline at the end of this
month but
um we're looking at maybe extending this
so if anyone's interested please come
and talk to me about it
right
so I'm going to present basically one
proof
uh so it'll be a bit of a technical talk
and I'll just use the Whiteboard and I'm
afraid the lights aren't all working so
uh please tell me if I need to write
bigger
um
so I'm going to give a follow-up to
jakob's talk
and
um
I guess
say something about one of the one of
the one of the open problems which is
the uh the complexity of jakob's proof
system at the end that I think he never
actually gave a name to
that's okay
okay
so I want to show that it has the same
strength as G1 which is a system that's
expected to be stronger than extended
trigger so stronger than Dr not
formalizable indirect
um so
I don't want to get into the details of
cutting planes and so on so I'm going to
give a slightly different presentation
of the main rule of the system this
dominance-based rule
so here is uh more or less a proof
system and I'm going to claim this is
the same as Jakob system
so your uh you're working essentially
with extended fragr for
well
or extended resolution or circuit
fragrance so we're dealing we're dealing
with uh sets of Clauses or sets of
formulas and we could think of these as
as polynomial size describing a circuit
and uh you're refuting things say so you
have some uh set of Clauses you want to
refute and you can use the rules of
extended fragr that's one thing you can
do in this system
but also you can use the following kind
of rule suppose you've well it's a
configurational system like uh Jacob
which is magnets you're working on some
set of formulas that it gets bigger and
smaller
suppose you arrive at some set of
formulas in variables X so this is meant
to be some set of propositional formulas
and this is just a a vector of formulas
it's not a negation
so uh you've derived gamma and then you
also write down a set of extension
actions
so these are defining some new variables
Z from X
so this is the kind of thing you can do
in extended fragr and you can also think
of it as you have a circuit that takes
variables X's inputs and outputs some
variable Z and Delta is just a
description of the circuit
and suppose you also write down a
substitution
which uh for the purposes of this talk
is going to mean a map from variables to
variables and this substitution takes X
variables and replaces them with some
other variables maybe from X or maybe
from Z and in general it could also do
uh it could also set someone to zero or
one
so we have these uh three things then we
also have a as a kind of auxiliary proof
written down on a piece of paper on the
side
we have a proof that gamma and Delta
together
uh prove this thing
so this is gamma under the Restriction
Omega
and this says that X under the
Restriction Omega is less than x so
X under the description Omega means we
just apply this uh this substitution so
we look at each variable and we maybe
leave it the same or maybe replace it
with a different variable from Z
depending on what ermica says so this
this this changes X into a different
Tuple of variables and then we're saying
that lexicographically this is less than
this so maybe X is written down as X1 up
to X N and after the substitution we
have Z1 up to z n and this is saying if
you think of these as binary strings
then lexicographically the string on the
left is lesser than the string on the
right
so this is you can write this as some
kind of formula of depth two or three
talking about the variables and it's
it's not a
it's not a fancy thing so this is um
this is what Jacob for example was doing
through this function X1 plus 2 x 2 plus
4 x 3 and so on here we're just assuming
we have some formula that defines
lexical graphic order
so if we have these three things then we
can conclude that the set we wrote down
was actually unsatisfiable so if we've
derived gamma and we have this then
we're able to finish the proof at this
point
so this is a proof system it's
um the similar rule Jakob had wasn't for
finishing the
proof straight away it was for deriving
a new Clause C but I don't really need
that so I'm not doing the C here I'm
just doing stopping the proof
so
um
so Neil to clarify the substitution is
really an arbitrary substitution or
because the way you said it sounded as
if x has to go to itself or to some
other through something it's an
arbitrary arbitrary substitution so we
just write down some substitution
[Music]
sorry
decisions
to the v's possibly so
so you want it for every value
Associated it should be smaller the
seeds are the right
I'm saying there's a formula uh like
legs
that's why
this is some extended trigger formula
defining let's figure out the ordering
and I'm saying if you do the
substitution then this is provable
so does it mean that in particular the
lengths of the string that you get the
substitution is that most the length of
the original yes but I mean we just
substitute the substitution is just
something that affects single variables
so we're taking a tuple of n variables
and just for each variable we're
applying Omega to it
so
the issue with the system is how much
logic do you need to prove soundness of
uh of this rule
so a kind of semi-formal proof of
soundness looks like looks like this
so I went out to show that gamma
actually is unsatisfiable uh in the
circumstance so let's
Alpha
be the least
assignment
such that Alpha satisfies gamma
foreign so here I mean Alpha is an
assignment to X variables and least just
means lexicographically least this is
the ordering we're always using
um sorry we assume that Alpha that gamma
is satisfiable then we take this
and then
um
we extend
Alpha to Alpha together with beta
that's the alpha together with beta
satisfies
gamma and Delta
so Alpha was an assignment to X
variables Delta is extension axioms
defining some Z variables so beta is an
assignment to Z variables so this is the
X and this is a z
so this is just we think of Delta as a
circuit and we just run the circuit on
Alpha we get what Z is and we write it
down as beta
then
um
by uh this condition
we have
that uh Alpha together with beta
yes
because uh it's just uh extension
actions so all Delta is doing is saying
how each Z variable is defined in terms
of X variables so we just we just do all
these things together
yes so it's a circuit Computing the
volume of Z we do the circuit we get
so we get the alpha together with beta
satisfies this thing
so I'm just repeating the last thing in
uh
um now if you look at this
we let
Alpha Prime
so this is an assignment so x and z
variables we're at Alpha Prime B this
thing
proposed with Omega
so Omega
tells us how to assign X variables if we
know how to assign x and z variables so
given any X variable we changed it to a
different variable we evaluated here so
this gives us a new assignment to X
variables
and then just working through the
definition of restriction
as Jacob said we get that uh
Alpha Prime satisfies gamma
so this is just the meaning of this so
if Alpha together with beta satisfies
gamma under the substitution that's the
same as taking out this applying the
substitution it satisfies gamma
and
Alpha Prime is lexicographically less
than Alpha
so you can think of this uh this Alpha
say as binary strings giving values to X
variables beta is to Z variables and
then this lets us produce a new string
for the X variables it satisfies gamma
by this and it's less than the one we
started with by this this is now a
contradiction
by a choice of alpha
so
um
this this is this is why it's sound the
same proof as well similar proof about
uh Jacob gave
and you can kind of see that uh if we
wanted to do something such a sorry
about this but this is maybe connected
to was it Alberta like Omega could in
fact could I think of Zen as being like
X1 Prime up to X and Prime and without
restriction just let
Omega map x i Prime to x i without the
prime because the circuit will do the
rest for me
I think I don't understand I mean this
is fairly flexible so you could copy all
the x's and costs as well if you wanted
but you mean just sort of work out in
advance what the new values are going to
be no I mean I don't need like I don't
need a general Omega I could just say
that Omega sense like I identify which
set variable carries the new variable
for my X variable
so that that Omega is just basically
projecting yeah
uh yes so
um
I think the consequence of what I say
that uh basically that's what you need
so you could put more restrictions but
for the full the full rule is system
yeah yeah well
I mean this Omega has uh
inputs or more we don't have exacts
I mean particular the Zeds will also be
uh working out internal modes in this
circuits but I think I'm getting a bit
far away from more questions
so as if you wanted to formalize this in
boundaristic or at all
then the uh the kind of business part of
it is actually finding the least
assignment here so you can do this proof
If you know how to find the least
assignment satisfying something
and I want to show that's actually
essential in that
um
[Music]
the proof system itself effectively
simulates this ability to minimize
things or to locally minimize them
so uh let me put this in terms of proof
complexity
of propositional perfume by state
so we're going to talk about some strong
uh proof systems so let's draw some
proof systems
so a valley weak system is uh is
resolution
and then here we have cutting planes
which I'm mentioning as it's the system
Jakob is building on and here we might
have something like ac0 frago
both of these are weaker than Fraga
and then above this we get to Extended
trainer
and this is where things like uh like
drock lives
equivalent to Extended Freight
so
um if you want to show that something is
stronger than extended fragr you're not
really going to be able to prove a
separation
but you can prove effectively hardness
results for some standard stronger
systems and there are some stronger
systems
and the one most I'm going to talk about
is called G1
and uh this can we go further it's
likely to feature there's G2 and so on
and
[Music]
um
what is
G1
so uh
Fraga
is equivalent to uh LK
which is the propositional
sequent calculus
so one standard way to write phrase is
that the proof is a is a series of
sequence and each sequence you have some
propositional formulas on the left and a
sequent arrow and then some
propositional formulas on the right
and you you reason to this
and this is sometimes called g0
and then uh G1 is the sequent calculus
the way you have slightly stronger
reasoning where you can have existential
quantifiers over Boolean values
so sequent now
rather than just having propositional
formulas you're allowed to quantify over
zero and one values so this is
effectively a shorthand notation for
saying it's true
but some possible binary value of x
so it's a compressed way of writing a
more expressive thing so a sequence in
G1 looks like this
and uh if you're proving
um we're in the world where we don't
ultimately want to prove or refute these
Quantified formulas we just want to
prove a refute unquantified formulas and
if you look at the unquantified formulas
you can repeat with it
d0 is f G1 is
up here uh G2 is allowing more
quantifiers and so on
and uh extended fragr is actually
equivalent to tree like
G1
and uh G1 is equivalent to tree like G2
and there's various relationships like
this
um and just to say something about maybe
about this case
so just to talk about One Direction of
this how would you show for example the
tree like G1
is simulated by extended fragrance
so what you would do is you'd say in G1
you're deriving sequence like this and
this is meant to mean that if everything
on the left is true then something on
the right is true
and you can take a tree like G1 proof
and when you derive this you can
inductively construct the circuits that
tells you how given X is witnessing the
left you could construct Y is witnessing
the right and you can build this up into
this kind of um
this kind of uh simulation and the other
direction is uh is harder
so
this way it has to be tree life does it
work uh not entirely but
um
but I don't want to talk about it
because it's not sure how much time
so where in this picture is uh is Jacob
system so it's built on cutting planes
but uh effectively with the extension
rules like extended fragrance plus the
other rule which is why I've written it
this way
and I'm going to claim it's exactly here
now
the thing about these g1s
and GIS is they correspond tightly to uh
to bound the arithmetic systems so I can
draw the kind of following picture of it
so we have G1
and we have a
extended Fraga
which is like tree like G1
and then this is actually corresponds to
boundaries s22
and this corresponds to PV
so the correspondence between PV and
extended fragr is uh is something that
goes back to the definition of these
classes and
um it's something like this it's
um PV
proves that for all binary strings
uh something is false
this is a PV formula
so this is some polynomial time property
of x
this is true if and only a
extended frager
has a short refutation
of the uh
translation of this
so I'm going to use this kind of
notation so what's going on here is this
is this is some formula uh about
polynomial time property I'm translating
it here into a Boolean formula by uh
silently picking some size some number
of bits and then here rather than
talking about strings here I'm talking
about strings of n Bits and these are
now meant to be Boolean variables for
the bits of of the number
and we can think of the way the way to
turn this into propositional formula is
we think of the circuit that expresses
Phi or inputs of this size
and this says that we run the circuit on
these Boolean variables and the answer
is one and we have a refutation of this
so uh in general we're talking about
provability of raw Pi B1 formulas and
from this point of view where we can
kind of silently pass between uh the
first order case and the uh the
propositional case
EF is the same as PV D1 is the same as
s22 S2 is stronger but if we're only
interested in formulas of this kind it's
the same
and then buy kind of old results in
boundary arithmetic
this is the same as T12
and this is the same as PV
plus an axiom that essentially says
we can solve
yeah that's problems
who is we
uh the Axiom so formally it's an axiom
saying that for every PLS problem it has
a solution
uniformity
uh yes I do I'm I'm sweeping that under
the carpet for today so let's not worry
about don't worry about uniformity
back to this for all uh about this kind
of ignoring issues of uniformity yeah
okay
so we already uh more or less saw T12
because that's what we use to prove
soundness here so now I want to kind of
do the other direction to show that
anything provable in
um in in this so G1 or or from PV plus
this thing is actually doable using this
in this system
uh I have five minutes which maybe is
not enough time so
um
so what is a PLS problem
foreign
X
is a triple
of a initial function an initial
solution the main and uh neighborhood
function
and the solutions
given such a problem
if
um
it's not the case that the initial value
is in the domain then everything is a
solution so we kind of force the initial
value to be in the domain
the first kind of solution
any uh why
such that
Y is a solution and uh
the neighbor of Y is not that's a
solution so I stopped writing the X for
now
and uh anyway
such that Y is a solution
and the neighbor of Y is not strictly
smaller than y there's an a PLS problem
when you keep applying the neighbor
you're meant to get strictly smaller and
smaller electrographically smaller
strings staying inside the solutions
until we find some kind of local minimum
and that's a solution that's our PLS
event to work
so um I'm claiming that G1 is the same
as more or less extended fragr plus this
rule saying that we can solve these
problems
so uh what is that
look like
um
so I'm going to skip at this point the
details of some of these translations
and then
argued by analogy maybe more than I
should just to claim the next thing
so
um
I'll just write the claim
inspect
so suppose
G1 refutes bisexual reputation some
formula
um Phi is
so uh here this is again this is some
kind of circuit about some propositional
values X
then
um by uh
by this characterization of G1 as PV
plus this and by the relation between PV
and extended trigger
um we can do some translation
and get the following then there exists
EF proofs
as follows
uh
from Firex
and um
what's this we can derive
foreign
so
it's if G1 refutes
uh Firex
that implies that extended fragr
informally proves
that uh Firex
implies there exists a PLS problem
with no solution
characterizing uh this thing as extended
frago plus the statement that every PLS
problem has a solution and a kind of
contrapositively interpreting that's as
meaning that if you can refute something
it means that when it's true this PLS
problem has no solution and this is
provable in extended fragrance so you
can do this and this is formally what
you end up with
so this is what it looks like to have a
PLS Pro with no solution you have uh if
Phi X is true
then uh
you can you can set y to be the initial
value and Y is in the solution space to
the PLS problem and it's approvable and
also you can prove that there's no
solution you can prove that if Y is in
the solution space and Z is the neighbor
of Y
then uh Z is in the solution space and
that is strictly smaller than y so this
is saying that uh sort of provably an
extended fragr we can repeatedly take
neighbors and we always stay inside the
solution space and we always get
strictly smaller so uh this says so this
is exactly under the assumption that Phi
X is true
uh you can iterate this problem and
never reach a solution
so
this is what we have
and now we can uh refuse
five
so
let me finish
foreign
in the system
so you start with
Phi
and then you uh derive uh so this is the
next thing you derive
so T is some polynomial time function
that gives you an initial solution so
this is like extension variables
defining a new circuit so we get uh this
and then we get the Phi X and BX
y
so this is because we know provably that
if Y is the initial thing then it's in
the domain and now we've thrown away
this
so we've derived this we have some
initial thing in our domain
and now I want to apply this rule
so we have
uh
Phi X
and DX y
and uh what's NY
is an extended frago
so this is going to be the auxiliary
proof we use here I'm just really
written down the lights last line there
again and we let uh
Omega
via substitution that takes X and Y
variables
and it Maps them to X Y and Z variables
and it just uh
replaces
uh y with z
so this is my description of the
substitution Omega
and then now look at the structure of
this so we'll take
these two formulas here and we'll call
them gamma
this thing is just defining some new
variables from old variables actually
really have written lines underneath it
so this is Delta this is extension
axioms
and then this thing
is now the same as gamma but we've just
replaced y's with Z's so this is gamma
restricted by Omega
and this thing is uh
saying that uh again this is this is
just
but why restricted by Omega is less than
y so y was one of the together the uh
the x's and y's form what I call the X
variables here and are ordering we only
care about the wipe up we didn't care
about the Xbox
so I'm claiming that uh this proof is
exactly the witness we need here
so uh by our rule we can now derive a
contradiction from what we've got and so
this this is how we've uh proved uh
we've simulated G1 by this dominant
system
the other direction simulation is just
by proving uh
uh proving the reflection of
the system yes so just because to do the
proof of reflection you just have to
take the minimum the T12 does it
so in particularly in this kind of proof
it's enough to apply the rule you want
yes
um
I well this is called work in progress
It's not completely written up I think
you're actually only even once but
probably you have to fail to the
robustness of the download Athletics
somehow to get that
okay I think thank you
foreign